today's show is sponsored by Terry Wogan
--zz Bohemian Rhapsody open your eyes
look up to the skies see this is the
technical difficulties we're playing
citation needed in front of me I have an
almost randomly selected Wikipedia
article from everybody's favorite
reliable source of knowledge and these
folks can't see it every fight they get
right is a point and a ding and the
special prize for particular good
answers which is good grief hmm so today
we are talking about the counts of index
the what sorry the count the counts
accounts how is that how they determine
how many uh sheets they're on a roll of
Agra yes the count of and right of
course the others can play with after by
count and Reks of Bohemia one she's not
enough to not enough three getting there
but we'll go for four just in case you
have to check in with him before you end
the Taunton gamblin how much you're
going to me he stood outside sliding
them under the door shaped by Shiga
what is sheet five worth to you ah I
have insatiable thirst for human blood
if the third count with the cow actually
submitted to his face non counting
instead instincts would not haha throw
it to a fine virgin on Sesame Street the
impossible Oh Bert and Ernie no hope
there I go to their house thinking
two-for-one they all know things I see
cannot be unseen Oh one night three for
one big bird very small yeah there was
there was a lovely quote from the grace
of Sesame Street why don't you know
we're tired of commenting on the birth
and early rumors which was their puppets
they don't exist below the waist no they
got a man's fist up their ass somewhere
back in that Randy did mention bohemia'
does anyone know what Bohemia actually
was Nigeria Germany yeah always now
Austria or so it wouldn't one of the
many states that coalesced into Germany
over the 19th century it's modern-day
Czech Republic Oh
a prisoner of Zenda inspiration
basically Bohemia wasn't it let's go
Xander yes yes the the novel retain Ian
and I don't I know the name but not much
else alone big castles in big pointing
hands and large caches and big swords
and all actually are there large castles
yep I love a lady with a flying buttress
gentlemen I am crenelated ha ha good
lord
repel all borders it's boiling trending
Terry Terry oguns castle defense of the
ship I think you're [ __ ] release we
found the British version of takeshi's
castle well actually I know I said no
offense he walks himself but he is to
lower level up Takeshi Kitano I'm all
right beat Takeshi massive huge movie
star of Japan yes you're doing it you be
Connery's castle oh that's the level of
mores mansion or something like that is
what you would be looking at Brosnan's
bungalow Oh
dalton's dolma isn't quite honest I've
got Brosnan's bungalows has been an
alternative Saturday morning kids yeah
now we're going to look at some silly
things outside the thought of Raju I
Drive around a little cult they have on
takeshi's castle spraying people with
what about laughing annoyed in a
military beautiful that's what he does
hahaha yeah but you have a big cocktail
a cigarette kissed impression of anybody
I've ever seen much of our dry with a
cashew in Waterloo so it was so good I
popped a button on Michelle
I wish that stunned by it I think the
idea is not that you have to like knock
out the paper targets but if you haven't
watched takeshi's castle this whole
sections lost on you all the tab just
yeah good five minutes come back it's
not that you have to shoot how long's
that you have to knock knock ease drink
out his handle Oh surely it is you have
to hit something very close to the
cocktail but if you hit the cocktail
lots of deaths and hence what if you
water it down you get lightly mind how
about you just cheat by having a
cocktail umbrella that's what the counts
of and X then hadn't dragged this back
in northern Dalmatia was it a bit spotty
yeah no I didn't know Dalmatian was
actually a region I've only just put two
and two together
yes very minute I'll sing all such as
hydrogen yeah I'll sign mirana by ah
really yeah all these little places that
came together to form Germany yeah
washed oh well don't wait a Dalmatian
Sixto weirdly it was a very short and
fat region which is where the sausage
doctor always said that fox hunting
would be instead of trying to ban it
just make them just make them I think it
was actually a monster raving loony
party idea but it works I've made them
replace beagles with sausage dogs well
so even sausage sausage dogs are hunting
dogs just for burrowing animals yeah
that's what being a sausage dog chase
also what's that what's the proper name
for a sausage dog hunt back on cuz it is
I'll be from the background yes so make
sure stuff Dalmatian is not actually in
Germany though it's the kind of you know
right now Europe don't take guess where
that easily are now I'm going a bit
further east we're also on the on the
Adriatic Sea not on the Adriatic Sea
it's not known about Croatian it's not
quite a really nice guys yeah Czech
Republic not Croatian yeah absolutely
right so we are looking for arts and
count in northern Dalmatia uh they
actually went extinct shortly afterwards
there's a complaint I'm sorry and this
with any under thought they were shot
and eaten for their meat / nudity by
colonized it's all about dogs and now
we're talking about the cows I went
extinct in the Direct Mail line
they didn't have any more girls
basically they all married off right all
the way around they didn't have any sons
all right yes girls do perhaps that's
what I'm answering yeah we're in that
we're in the 13th century it's just
decline just on the male line that's
changing the UK in the last few years
just before the birth of prevent George
thank you I was about calling prince was
named Whitney is possibly treason Prince
George thing is that is valley's kings
and queens of the country sort until
after our lifetime yeah the 22nd century
yes yes Wow
salt that out that's what you call
longevity that's really got a permanent
institution we've got oh I don't if it
will be Charles or not I've heard
different then you got oil so you're
William and then you've got him so it's
all blokes for the rest of our life no
unless we get a gun no sorry but
actually it's gonna be a sausage heavy
morning it has been throughout history
default setting so I'm looking through
and there is just an enormous amount of
genealogy and names and intrigue in the
court here don't want to say get some
some probs of Bavarian names that could
be in the hands no hands strangely
enough that we're they were all know why
they died out I mean they were
hands-free oh yes
point you know I know I can't give you
points they say it
I just realized that whenever I hit that
button I do this kind of thing with my
Lizzie I'm not sure why can we just get
a freeze-frame of that right now
Lord Vick
yeah it looks a good shower actually
nope oh no John old is exactly right at
the very first one
Arnold count of deezen merited Gizella
of Schweinfurt nice Pigford yeah pretty
much yes Ivan wants to take what the
what the foot in that is shrine is
definitely swine that's it River are not
quite your very cloaks ford ford point
over there literally swine points where
you crossing why you put things through
the rail crossing i love it as a juror
football god Schweinsteiger oath of that
pig farmer you see other what you do
translate member wife is that a little
bit you know of translating foreign
footballers names you know third pig
farmer and icg got that in yeah
peg farmer he's playing surprisingly
well considering he's been up since dawn
like their milk pigs do they say thank
you good here for door no would miss the
obvious one we've missed auto oh one of
those there's also pop oh nice oh he
says like a children's clown popover ii
Margrave of carniola yeah feels and
thrice yes please and if he doesn't
introduce himself like that every time
there is something wrong probably
doesn't introduce himself very much at
all anymore
he'll if he didn't at the time I buy a
Margaret of carry on I would like some
petrol I mean we're talking us on who
died more than 900 years ago I would
like some hey hi I'm Margaret carry Ola
Twix please
I was idea of motorway service stations
on medieval high tracks they would have
been things that I would have it
wouldn't be what aging player I would
have been coaching in Bundys I'm the
idea you pull off the slip road on this
hay truck this is it this ugly
uninterested person run foggy fish and
chips have been sat there for 10 hours
you cannot get a Frankfort from these
people for look at the prices they
charge
I shall go over T manner of ginn step
it is not warm it is cold these should
not be eaten in such a fashion but there
be tax if we warm with a very attacks if
we warm them Sir
yes I know I set the taxes nice fine
actually get cold anyway I'm only on my
way somewhere else
I shall hate it on my horses exhaustion
ah I just I just realized essentially
that pasty type thing is like a medieval
tax it's the colour in the commencing
you'd expect King John to say Robin Hood
store yes the kids Robin Hood story of
course I'll do koala death but when it
does involve taxing pasties yeah
and as I thought I would have to pull
over at a staging place I so liberal you
dropped into Wogan again here so my
breeches and I must take a quick call
these previous are cleaned twice a day
please tell management if you kind of
run this little analog clock on the wall
running rounds a minute since last
gravely she's gonna straight yeah you
could never find a favor from these
things no it's just a peasant strung up
by defeat haha and you've only got so
much rope to load and down running one
his grip is not strong enough they are
rigged they are rig here some can
disease the child the the Bears are just
massively waited another actual bears I
do not even want this I think we're if
the Maid Marian and Mary men's yeah
right okay at the end of the show Gary
congratulations yeah
oh I'd forgotten that God said it does
about every time there's a um you have
1/2 hours racing around the coast
desperately try and collect clams with a
famous ballerina in Darcy muscles muscle
hustle so enjoy that that's been my gray
that's been Gary Brannen that's been
Chris John I've been Tom Scott and we'll
see you next time
and that was our show if you liked it
leave us a comment or better yet share
it around to your friends we're trying
not to be too needy but seriously share
it around and there are more than 30
audio episodes of our reverse trivia
podcast over at Tech deaf Co UK